so first of all congratulations on the
movie um I saw it again last night and
it's so much fun but it's loaded with so
many twists and turns it's very hard to
talk about so I want to throw a
curveball at the beginning uh which is
not about this film you have done so
many amazing roles in your career but
there's going to be people out there
that have never seen your work if
someone has never seen anything you've
done what is the first thing you'd like
them watching and why the first thing I
like for them to watch uh
such an obvious answer for me but it is
no I'd say uh film called
187 just because it is something that's
so different from anything else that
they'll see uh in terms of who most
people think I am and Matthew what what
are you saying to recommend well I had
to again during lockdown I got my kids
to watch P fiction oh they're old enough
now yeah yeah and and they were like man
Sam Jackson is unbelievable I was like
yeah they probably was unbelievable come
on no no no they were like they lik
better than they liked everybody in the
movie they're girls girls like girls no
no no they loved the they loved it they
were like this is cool um we I heard the
bloody Big Mac versus Royale all the
time for about for weeks of them saying
that but they they loved Pulp Fiction
yeah that's the great thing about that
movie there's a certain group of kids
become of age every year that they can
watch it and all of a sudden I become
cool again so it's fine yeah um I don't
mean to bring up family but your kids
are literally responsible for so many
little things in this movie including
the the the Cat backpack uh from the
Taylor Swift documentary can you sort to
talk about pulling influences from what
your kids have been showing you um well
basically in the first draft there was
no cat right the film um if you know
that there's no cat in the damn thing
and and I was
like sorry I take that back there was a
cat in the first scene and then she goes
on the adventure and leaves the cat
behind and and I was working on the
script with Jason I said Jason they got
to have something
more you know conflict but it's going to
be something a fun conflict between
these two characters otherwise you know
it's hard to go from A to Z from the
Americans um and and then I saw the
Taylor Swift thing the the P was it P
cat cat pack backpack whatever you the
thing and that made me laugh and I went
oh my God I can put a cat in the back of
that and they can go on this whole
adventure and argue around over the cat
so that's where it came it for me it was
weirdly a dramatic narrative conflicting
device and then it it's grown into this
much bigger thing I I I'm definitely I
was looking at the Press notes and you
guys have talked about how or maybe it
was joking around when you say Sam is
directable uh he is he knows it right so
I am curious what is it actually like
cuz you are such a gifted actor what is
it like as a director when you're on set
with Sam and maybe you want something
else like can you sort of talk about
that Dynamic on set well can you imagine
if Jimmy Hendrick or Eric Clapton or
Cayman and said I'm G to do a guitar
solo and you go yeah why don't you try
it like this I was like nah let let him
sing and I'll just get him in focus and
we talk about it but you know it's my
job is as you said it before you know
John Houston said directing is 90%
casting and if you get people like this
it's 99.5% casting so once you've had
the discussion you know that's like I
understand what he's telling me I
understand what he wants uh you give me
the tone of the scene and you know I'll
show you what I'm planning to do and if
you don't like it before we do it then
you tell me then yeah you know or we can
discuss it then and I'll and I'll tell
you why you should like
it yeah he just he just nailed my
point